Egocentric thinking is the inability to look at the world through somebody
else's perspective. Piaget came up with a very clever test to measure this,
called the Three Mountain Test. Here, he would have a child sit and look at
these three mountains and tell him from direction of left to right what he
says. So, from your perspective the child would see a blue top mountain, a
plane mountain and a red top mountain. Next, you would ask a child what
somebody in my position would see. Inevitably the child would say, I would see
the same thing, meaning a blue top mountain, a plain mountain and a red top
mountain. However, as you can see my perspective, I actually would see a red
top mountain, a plain mountain and a blue top mountain. Again, egocentric
thinking is an inability of the child to take himself out of his own skin, and
look at the world from somebody else's perspective.